Ugh.
>> What?
>> Come on, nothing.
Ugh, come on!
>> What?
>> Nothing, you know what,
I just can't deal with this,
the buttons are too small.
So you know what,
I'm not going to buy these shoes,
I just can't deal with typing my address
in one more time on this small screen.
>> Yeah
>> What website is it.
Yikes, they should do better.
>> I know, okay, so
my phone isn't actually on.
But this scene isn't all
that uncommon online.
It's hard to type on a small screen.
So if it's hard to type the form
doesn't go through, and
then the user abandons the form.
This is particularly sad,
if you're an online retailer and
you just missed a sale.
>> Right, we could leverage
to autocomplete attribute.
It tells the browsers to automatically
fill the user's saved information into
a form.
>> Yeah, that sounds pretty useful.
>> It is, here let me show you how.